[Applaudissements]
la purée de piments et 3 smoothie frey
son attention c'est parti
elle est née quand quai à la purée de
piment à cfi série la purée de piments
et l'effet des directives fleurs il sait
pas où ça ma fille vous dites quoi comme
insulte ou trou du cul sans cesse vous
le dites quoi en voiture tous à chaque
fois que j'ai une contrariété
ah ouais et là vous en avez une
cartouche dans la voiture je voulais
dissous car d'une carrosserie filppula
et vous les poules et poulets pas dans
un prochain film un truc comme ça sans
rien merci pour lui
c'est pas là ça vous choque pas plus que
ça à penser des pouvoirs le genre du
film voilà c'est ça c'est toi pouvait
pas l'image oui alors oui comme dit si
c'est pau elle n'est pas tout à fait un
petit ligne c'est à dire qu'elle appelle
pense à tout petit jeu c'est vrai ou pas
elle pense à tout petit peu d'un côté
c'est ce qu'on a fait une pub elle
propose à côté
voilà c'est vrai non il a raison tient
du rased